ich holte mir leid
[Musik]
ich heiße alle mal ich bin 18 ihren im
sommer geburtstag
während die nase und julia träumt davon
eine große schauspielerin zu werden das
ist schwierig aber nicht unmöglich
denn das theater hora in zürich bietet
seit neuestem eine zweijährige lehre für
geistig behinderte an die nötige
begabung bringt julia mit vor ein paar
wochen hat sie mit der ausbildung
angefangen im moment übt sie im theater
hora gehört es fast ein steiler weg der
am schluss eine ungeahnte wendung nehmen
wird mit einer kleinen kamera möchte uns
julia die welt auch ein bisschen aus
ihrer perspektive zeigen und sich die
filme von mir
das mache judith hermann
ich bin deprimiert dass ich mich ist er
und holt die häusermann sind julias
eltern und das ist der
ausbildungsverantwortliche des theaters
hof
er hat ihnen gerade mitgeteilt dass
julia die dreimonatige probezeit
bestanden dass du spieler hat auch
bewegen also weiß die begeistert sich
sowie ein spieler
die sieht so schön so ist ihm egal das
gibt denn so leicht dass es extrem ganz
ganz lässig ist die liga siebten ist
dass du einfach noch wieviel
kuscheleinheiten braucht damit man immer
auf basis die anderen dafür die
verdächtigt werden wenn diese zu klein
ist und wie du verstehst du was ich
meine aber du sagt meint raschest der
woche wie schön geredet und ja da musste
ich etwas mache ich ein wachsen
und ich will dich bin
julia das dritte kind von esther und
ruedi häusermann ist vor 18 jahren mit
einem chromosomen defekt mit dem
sogenannten down syndrom zur welt
gekommen
die eltern wussten es bereits während
der schwangerschaft und hatten es bei
der geburt sofort allen mitgeteilt der
text zurück schreibe das ja aussicht
nach haben mir die hand einfach das rind
war das irgendwie einfach die gedanken
und gebete nicht angezogen haben zu
einem werde dann fällt und ihren alltag
seite konzert sehr viel licht wenig
aussprechen sich gut dafür die miete für
mich ist das ein klacks ich wette das
kind abtreiben also als mini und
kleidung werden nicht siegen 2000 für
mich ist dass ich nicht die frage du
bist ganz so wichtige rolle die das man
dir bradl ist dann zehn zuschauer
hauptbüro was stinkt den verbrauchern
ist mächtig oder gar das heißt wir ja du
musst es nicht sogar direkte das noch
arbeitete gleich darauf weist
rauszuschmeißen
was kann sie zur korrektur
sie schaut dann zu schauen sich und
juliane geist der gründerväter
positionen schafft limit die rede
okay okay du hast es gut macht
magisch vatikan ist sie aktiviert das
bist dass du du bist die einzige zur
schau die ganz sie traurig und darum ist
alles was du machst hatte doppelte
bedeutung da gibt es zum beispiel los
jetzt liest du brauchst waren sie da
waren sie doch ihr die liebe ist ich
mache diesen beistand brauchen leute
oder wo sind da die sie haben ich und du
steht in bronze und felix ohne großes
bravo über das aussehen wie andere
teenager hat auch julia ihre vorbilder
sie will aber nicht so sein wie diese
julia glaubt jeweils zwei die
angehimmelte person
das führt immer wieder zu diskussionen
zwischen mutter und tochter
ihre große liebe ist ihr sieben jahre
älterer bruder jem machst du schon julia
schwärmt im moment noch für einen
anderen dominik mit ihm geht sie heute
zum ersten mal ohne eltern aus
[Musik]
so beschwichtigen
bitte bitte
dieses thema ist ein dauerbrenner
esther bild darum mit ihrer tochter noch
mal reden bevor dominik kommt
[Musik]
julia geht sehr offen auf leute zu die
ihr gefallen
da kann es schon mal zu
missverständnissen kommen ich dachte sie
genau wo sie außer direktion für
deutschland aber sie wären die
konsequenzen tragen also mit
integriertem innere mit hormon pflaster
ob er einfach sicherheitshalber aus im
moment hat sie eigentlich kein trusted
mal wohl bis sie ist auch die richtig
denn ich sie das erzählen und sind
deutlich gesagt er 76 bis bregenz das
wesen das sie dass sie korrekt sondern
wann wird das dominik feiert heute
seinen vierzehnten geburtstag und lädt
julia deshalb ins theater ein
sie kennen sich erst seit kurzem
also ja ich bin mit dem bus vom bahnhof
vor bekommen und dann ist die räte von
blogger twitter größer wenn die airbags
behinderte unsere sache und dann haben
sie auch schützen danach ende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weil dominik geburtstag hatte und julia
quasi eine berufskollegin von jörg
schneider ist dürfen die beiden nach der
vorstellung in die künstlergarderobe so
julia ich das geld sei ja gut die faust
heißt so etwas schwierig
[Musik]
es sind drei relativ viel zu lassen sich
nieder anschluss sehr dass du mich das
auch sehr gut möglich der privaten zu
ändern
mit die jungs von außen und dann mit dem
zug und gierigen im baumhof
[Musik]
nach ich dufte
und die wurst da nicht
olympia
[Musik]
morning
julia ist einfach besser spielen
thomas ist thomas schon mal was von
thomas ranicki vergeht aber ich kann
nicht speziell die meint kanadas juden
gemeinsam beispiel oder dass gott alle
das spiel geht darum dass wir als gruppe
findet die größte erfahrung flexibel
das heißt also trust in you weiß nie was
passiert
theorie müssen sie für diese lehre nicht
gefallen aber julia liebt es sich selbst
immer wieder neue aufgaben zu stellen
ja ja ja ja ja ich werde mir das
wichtigste das sie wirklich überzeugt
sind dass das richtige nicht was sie
macht dass sie spiellust wieder kann
entwickeln dass sie die halter die
spiellust ja eigentlich dass du
wahnsinnig dass ich persönlich finde mit
einem was sie macht oder
[Musik]
ja
u23
[Musik]
so passt so weiss
wenn du nicht mitspielt dem motto bürger
kritik zu bekommen heißt auch ernst
genommen zu werden damit umzugehen ist
für julia manchmal schmerzhaft
[Musik]
das ich fühle mich gut
das ist mein vater war sehr jungen sind
dass der opa sie mir die tour die echte
team morgen
ich zeige euch bundeswehr spielt vor mir
was bin ich als hinter sich wie viel es
konkret um eine grenze dass ich meine
hand alles nicht so plakativ android
solutions spaziert sind oder so
gratulieren
und er hat enorm ausstrahlt
aber natürlich bin ich das schaffe und
ich haben sich die beiden älteren kinder
sind längst ausgeflogen
marien ist die mittlere der drei
geschwister und vier jahre älter als
julia sie liebt ihre schwester sehr
[Applaus]
frankfurt oder ich mir behinderten
solche aussagen seines kollegen ohne
zuvor die behinderten rolle gespielt
dingen sich auch julia aktien die sie
mir gegangen mit denen viel zusammen
machen aufspielt und lacht
theater ua vier monate sind seit beginn
der lehre vergangen juli als erste
premiere faust 1 und 2
[Musik]
ok
[Applaus]
[Musik]
froh im herz froh da wacht kolleg
zug besteht
[Musik]
hurra
manches muss wo schlachtfest hoffe dass
dort nur sechster war etwa so wie du es
dir
[Musik]
das war
diese
mit der
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der wind ist schön dass wir es richtig
ausspielen
[Gelächter]
festival vorstellig dass er punkte
domini sich am montag im onyx am
nachmittag dominique wird nicht kommt
weil julia vom ausbildungsplan hier nur
vier tage am theater sein kann musste
sie einen tag pro woche zusätzlich an
einem geschützten arbeitsplatz arbeiten
darum schnuppert sie in dieser wäscherei
[Musik]
ok
sein
julia möchte am liebsten sofort anfangen
aber es gibt wartezeiten und sie kann
erst in ein paar wochen hier beschäftigt
werden
das ist für sie schwer zu begreifen
immer wieder muss julia bitter erfahren
dass andere menschen andere pläne haben
können auch in der liebe bietet mit
ich kann das nicht mehr hatte und der 1
ja ich habe das immer wüsste ich das
sage das ist natürlich sowieso wo
eigentlich mir die ganze zeit erlebt hat
dass so manche relativ einsam sind weil
sind wickelt sich mit freundschaften mit
nicht behinderten menschen eigentlich
freundschaft wie andere die dem autor
und der wirtschaft dass das hat sich
sehr für sich eigentlich immer dass ich
liebe dich person
weißt du was ich mag die september 2011
julia hat das erste liga geschafft heute
ist premiere eines neuen stücks ente tod
und tulpe eine politische inszenierung
vom umgang mit dem tod
mit dem spieler das nicht schön für mich
so würde er ich da der applaus gilt
heute nicht nur der aufführung sondern
auf den ersten beiden schauspielern mit
prämiertem lehrabschluss miranda und
matthias tradition sieht mir die
ausbildung
[Musik]
bestaunt und jetzt muss nämlich ronis
töpfe in gröst rahmig immer für indien
und machen am liebsten und süßwaren
bruder team und seine freundin angie mit
julia in die disco la viva jim hat immer
ein bisschen angst um seine
kontaktfreudige schwester
ich halte auf großer bühne irgendwie ist
es auch nicht auch lieder die
beschützerin stinkt das ist wieder eine
so locker aus dem jura gehen unter sich
lösen und und einfach dort sehr gut und
so und das ist so machen alle gesicht
geschrieben
naja so sich für mich ist distanz und
malz für mich kürze zu und und das
problem über das reden
ich hoffe es hält nicht mit behinderung
ich kann schlecht
[Musik]
ja
also
[Musik]
neben sich
problem
[Musik]
es ist februar 2012 gewählt
julia kommt ihrem traum vom erfolg einen
wichtigen schritt näher
ein bekannter französischer choreografen
scheidet sich mit dem auto und den
lehrlingen ein stück zu inszenieren
jerome bel möchte dass sie keine rolle
sondern einfach sich selbst spielen
[Musik]
das ist fürs publikum sehr anspruchsvoll
aber auch für die schauspielerinnen
das stresst also im letzten tagen immer
mit mittelstufe es langweilt sie
vielleicht recht aber es tut mir leid
sie müssen das tun
ich bin der regisseur
also ich denke es ist interessant
vertrauten ja wenn ihr nicht
einverstanden zeigt dann könnte mir das
sagen und wir suchen eine lösung
aber natürlich ist der stick nicht für
sie sondern für das publikum als
choreograf lässt er sie auch tanzen sie
suchen sich ihr stück selbst aus dass
hingegen gefällt allen sehr und dank
schermbeck werden sie von theatern in
ganz europa eingeladen
damit hatte niemand gerechnet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
julia wird im sommer 20 jahre alt und
gleichzeitig die lehre abschließen
es geht so langsam ans abnabeln auch bei
hausammann ausgezeichnet
es zeichnet sich ab juli will allmählich
ihre eigenen wege gehen sie leer macht
und abschließt und sei aber dass man
nachher nur vokaty wohnform für sie und
für sie eigentlich klar dass sie vor der
stunt ihr aktiv los angeles in wien
dann hat es einfach nicht stopfen
das gilt besonders war wieder
interessantes über die andere wurden von
dir und ganz sicher weil das ich mir
egoisten knurrt das meeresleben fertig
aber und vor sinnvoll und klug dass man
mir um aussterben oder hinfällig werden
irgendwie dass das nicht romantisch wo
sie sich dann als trainer oder sondern
das dass sie jedes ereignis aber schon
vorne auf der eine braucht hat
im juni 2012 erfüllen wir julia einen
traum und fahren mit ihr nach köln
sie ist eingeladen die studios ihrer
lieblingsserie verbotene liebe zu
besuchen
ich kann nicht
ich weiß es
30 30
über 4.100 folgen gibt es bereits von
verbotene liebe gedreht wird heute eine
hochzeit fast alle stars aus ihrer
lieblingsserie es hinter
wieso also auf gesehen hatte auf
ich bin der tore kannst du dann so ich
muss los
[Musik]
die chance dir unsere geschichte wenn
wir jetzt wissen julia kopieren tags und
immer so wenn du jeden fall
dann aber geht julia ziemlich
unerschrocken auf den mann zu der die
fäden zusammenhält den regisseur gerät
sie ich gucke mir die nächste szene
drehen in welchen einstellungen wo die
kamera ständig durch hereinfahren was
zuerst drehen
das ist die erste kamera position und
wir sitzen die einzelnen schauspieler
und das wird derzeit sozusagen so kleine
story etwas so war einfach festlegen in
welcher reihenfolge der welt
red rose
manchmal auch nicht
das ist ich weiß sondern alle habe ich
meine ganze später
sich becker
[Musik]
und da ist er ja auch noch hier ist für
mich aber auch angucken oder aber nicht
aufgeregt sein
bei uns heute so auch immer
schauspielerin sein oder
da bist du heute ja quasi dann schon
dabei so ein bisschen das ist dann so
wie du es dir vorgestellt hast ja ja
schon ein bisschen was gesehen ja mein
magen den christian hier hat wenn wir
mal ein bisschen gucken heimlich sehen
bisher
also ist es immer wenn die ganzen leute
da sind wir jetzt kurzem ich wiederkomme
üben wir das nochmal ja du bleibst hier
noch eine weile warten
julias weg zum glück die grünen wäre
wenn tatsächlich ein rollenangebot aus
köln käme
hallo
julias karriere nimmt eine unglaubliche
wende der von ihr anfänglich zum teufel
gewünscht cher umwelt hatte mosel hurra
nämlich die bühnen europas geöffnet sie
sind unter anderem nach berlin paris und
brüssel eingeladen
dass julia die lehre erfolgreich
abgeschlossen hat geht fast ein bisschen
unter weil sie vor dem er abschluss
schon profi schauspielerin geworden ist
sie braucht auch den zusatzjob in der
wäscherei nicht mehr im juli 2012 reißen
andere in die ferien
die rohre druck bereist nach avignon als
weltweit größte theaterfestival julias
vorstellungskraft allerdings reicht nur
viel viel weiter auf ihrem ipod hat sich
nämlich soeben teenie star justin bieber
gemeldet
ja
äußerst beliebt
[Musik]
ihr stück mit jerome bel heißt die segel
zettel also behinderten theater ob das
ein guter name ist
[Musik]
ja unbedingt
warum
richtig so wenn man dann natürlich macht
die da alle drei sie ein engel
wenn ich merke dass ihr euch abgeben
wenn du jetzt wieder aufbauen willst du
damit
mit oder ohne darm
wir wollen euch danken
ich weiß ich kann aber sehr reiche ich
kann du bist du hast meine down syndrom
tritt am 21
ich kann damit sicher bekannt werden ich
muss nicht denken wird neu gebaut werden
ohne dass wegträumen ausblick
[Musik]
400 leute haben den theaterplatz
sämtliche vorstellungen in avignon sind
praktisch ausverkauft julia ist
angekommen
ich reiche julia häußermann
ich bin nie und wenn ich bin ich ja
später
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der soeben ausgestrahlte dokumentarfilm
ist auf dvd erhältlich
bestellen sie unter der eingeblendeten
telefonnummer oder gleich jetzt im
internet
der shop punkt sf.tv